Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In the first century BC, the philosopher Athenodorus was looking for a house to rent in Athens. He found one at a remarkably good rate, given how large it was, and he soon realised why. On the very first night he was working late, when a ghost appeared with a long beard and bristling hair, clanking its iron fetters. The ghost led him outside and indicated a spot in the courtyard. And the next day, when Athenodorus had the spot dug up, his men found a pile of old bones.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。公元前一世纪，哲学家阿特诺多鲁斯（Athenodorus）在雅典寻找出租的房屋。考虑到房子很大，他以非常优惠的价格租到了一间，但很快他就明白了原因。就在第一天晚上，他工作到很晚，这时一个留着长胡子、头发蓬乱的鬼魂出现了，拖着沉重的铁链。鬼魂把他引到外面，指了指庭院里的一个地方。第二天，阿特诺多鲁斯让人挖开那个地方，他的手下发现了一堆陈旧的白骨。
And after the bones had been laid to rest, the house was haunted no more. Tom Holland, that is a great story, isn't it? It's a fabulous... It's from Pliny, isn't it, from Pliny? It is, the younger Pliny. But I remember it from childhood.ny it is younger plinny um but i remember it from um childhood i had a the bumper book of both ghosts and that was the very first story in it and it had a fabulous um black and white illustration of athenodorus and the ghost with the manacles
在这些白骨被妥善安葬后，这间房子就再也没有闹过鬼了。汤姆·霍兰德，这真是一个精彩的故事，不是吗？这是一个极好的……这是出自普林尼（Pliny），对吧，出自普林尼？没错，是小普林尼。但我从童年时代就记得这个故事。嗯，是小普林尼，但我从童年时代就记得它。我有一本关于鬼魂的合集，那是里面第一个故事，书中还有一幅精彩的黑白插图，画着阿特诺多鲁斯、鬼魂以及那副手铐。
and the beard creeping up behind him so i i remember it very very vividly um and the ghosts have have always i've always loved stories about ghosts um and in fact over the course of the lockdown one of my activities was to go on ghost hunting walks across london so i did two huge walks you know up to the tower across london back down again and i went right right the way up to um highemetery, which boasts perhaps the most haunted road in Britain. It's got the Highgate vampire. It's got a kind of strange psychic blob that creeps up on people and then leaps away.
还有那个在他身后悄悄靠近的胡子，所以我记得非常非常清楚。嗯，我一直都很喜欢关于鬼魂的故事。事实上，在封锁期间，我的活动之一就是去伦敦进行“猎鬼”徒步旅行。我进行了两次长距离的徒步，你知道，一直走到伦敦塔，穿过伦敦，然后再走回来。我还一直走到了海格特公墓（Highgate Cemetery），那里号称拥有英国最闹鬼的道路。那里有海格特吸血鬼，还有一种奇怪的灵异团块，会悄悄靠近人们然后跳开。
All kinds of terrifying things. But at the top of that road, there is Pond Square, which boasts perhaps my favourite ghost of all time pond square is where francis bacon in 1626 attempted to deep freeze a chicken by killing it plucking it gutting it and stuffing it with snow so you remember that story and and bacon gets he gets a chill and ends up dying and so people always remember bacon but they don't remember the chicken. It's the chicken who haunt the area.
各种各样可怕的东西。但在那条路的尽头，有一个池塘广场（Pond Square），那里有着我个人最喜欢的鬼魂。池塘广场是弗朗西斯·培根（Francis Bacon）在1626年试图冷冻一只鸡的地方，他杀了它、拔了毛、掏空内脏并塞进雪里。你还记得那个故事吧？培根着了凉，最终去世了，所以人们总是记得培根，却不记得那只鸡。正是那只鸡在那个地区游荡。
Well, nothing was seen or heard of it until the Second World War, when firefighters reported seeing a large bird unable to fly because its feathers had been plucked, running round in circles and pathetically flapping the stumps of its wings. It is still occasionally seen dropping outlapping the stumps of its wings. It is still occasionally seen dropping out of the sky with a squawk. It is always shivering. Wow. So I don't think we're qualified to pronounce on the supernatural. I mean, we're barely qualified to pronounce on the natural.
嗯，直到第二次世界大战之前，都没有人见过或听过它。当时消防员报告说看到一只大鸟，因为羽毛被拔光了而无法飞行，它在原地转圈，可怜地拍打着残缺的翅膀。它偶尔还会被看到从天空中掉下来，伴随着一声尖叫。它总是瑟瑟发抖。哇。所以我觉得我们没有资格对超自然现象发表评论。我的意思是，我们甚至连对自然现象发表评论的资格都勉强。
That's true. So I think, do you have a guest for us today? I do. And I have the best guest we could possibly have. It's Roger Clark, who wrote what I think is the best book on ghosts that I've ever read. And it's a book not just about ghosts, but about the history of ghosts. So absolutely perfect. Ghosts, a natural history, 500 years of searching for proof. And I read it this Christmas, because obviously at Christmas, you should read a ghost stories and things. And my wife had bought a kind of chair you get in a gentleman's club.
确实如此。那么，你今天为我们请到嘉宾了吗？请到了。而且我请到了我们能请到的最好的嘉宾。他就是罗杰·克拉克（Roger Clark），他写了我读过的关于鬼魂的最好的书。这本书不仅是关于鬼魂的，更是关于鬼魂历史的。所以绝对完美。书名是《鬼魂：自然史，五百年的寻证之旅》（Ghosts, a Natural History, 500 Years of Searching for Proof）。我是在这个圣诞节读的，因为显然在圣诞节，你应该读读鬼故事之类的东西。我妻子买了一种你在绅士俱乐部里能见到的那种椅子。
She bought it on eBay or something. I put it in front of the fire, glass of sherry, Roger's book. One of the great, great reading experiences of my life. And we'd begun the podcast then and I thought we have to get him on and we have to talk ghosts. So Roger, thank you so much. Such a pleasure. And yes, every day at five o'clock, I was sort of rapt to see which peculiar story you would pick out. And yes, I do throw in a few strange ones. Well, there are so many peculiar stories, isn't it? Because essentially you are... Let's actually begin with a question which has been sent in by rob long and he says how much does background matter are british
她是在eBay上还是什么地方买的。我把它放在壁炉前，倒上一杯雪利酒，读着罗杰的书。这是我一生中最棒的阅读体验之一。那时我们刚开始做播客，我就想我们一定要请他来，我们一定要聊聊鬼魂。所以罗杰，非常感谢你。非常荣幸。是的，每天五点，我都会着迷地看你会挑选出什么奇特的故事。是的，我确实会加入一些奇怪的故事。嗯，有太多奇特的故事了，不是吗？因为本质上你是在……让我们从罗伯·朗（Rob Long）发来的一个问题开始吧，他问背景有多重要，英国的
ghost sightings different say to french how much do the events of the time seem to affect what people report and that essentially is your thesis isn't it that ghost stories evolve to reflect the assumptions and the beliefs and perhaps the tensions and the paranoias of the age in which these ghosts appear yes and i didn't really realize this until i started reading the writing the book and uh i had this sort of childhood obsession with ghosts and i wanted to see see a ghost and uh and then uh as i went to university and so forth i got rather embarrassed by my interest in it and uh pitched pitched the book it got written and i i noticed there was a definite shift in what people wanted from ghosts and um not so much do i found the question do
鬼魂目击事件和法国的有什么不同？时代事件在多大程度上影响了人们的报告？这本质上就是你的论点，对吧？即鬼故事的演变反映了这些鬼魂出现时代的假设、信仰，或许还有紧张局势和偏执。是的，直到我开始写这本书之前，我并没有真正意识到这一点。我童年时对鬼魂有一种痴迷，我想见鬼，然后当我上大学等等之后，我对这种兴趣感到有些尴尬。我提出了这本书的构思，它被写了出来，我注意到人们对鬼魂的需求发生了明显的转变。嗯，我发现“鬼魂是否存在”这个问题并不是特别有趣，我想找出人们从鬼魂身上想要得到什么。
ghosts exist not really very interesting i wanted to find out what people wanted from ghosts. And I realized that you could see definite shifts in what the ghost experiences over about every hundred years. And the other thing from my childhood is that in the 70s is that, you know, we were the poor man of Europe. We were terrible at everything, but we were terrible everything but we were really good at ghosts and and and we were the most we were the most haunted country in the world and it was just uh this was a marvelous and an involving thought and so i i wanted to go back and look at that and why were there so many ghost books and famous ghost hunters in the 70s i actually wrote them as a school boy and um got sort of involved in discussing ghosts and there were different kinds of ghosts clearly
我意识到，你可以在大约每一百年左右的鬼魂经历中看到明显的转变。关于我童年的另一件事是，在70年代，你知道，我们是欧洲的穷人。我们在各方面都很糟糕，但我们在鬼魂方面却非常擅长。我们是世界上闹鬼最严重的国家，这真是一个奇妙且引人入胜的想法。所以我想要回顾并研究一下，为什么在70年代有那么多鬼故事书和著名的捉鬼人？我还是个小学生时就写过这些，并参与了关于鬼魂的讨论，显然有不同种类的鬼魂。
i worked out there about 10 or so varying kinds of ghosts um and it all sort of went went from there and i i noticed that there was some specific issues about uh britain and the UK, and it involved the Civil War and, to quite a big extent, the suppression of Catholicism, the comeback of Catholicism in the 1780s and so forth, and this fear of resurgent Catholicism. But also the sprinklings of German belief, which came in with the various members of the royal family, obviously all the Celtic stuff. And it's a very specific mix of belief.
我整理出了大约10种左右不同的鬼魂，一切就从那里开始了。我注意到关于英国和联合王国有一些具体的问题，它涉及内战，在很大程度上还涉及对天主教的压制，以及1780年代天主教的回归等等，以及对天主教复兴的恐惧。但也包括随着王室成员引入的德国信仰的渗透，显然还有所有的凯尔特元素。这是一种非常独特的信仰混合体。
And also we seem to have this specific idea that ghost stories are sort of comforting, which is quite, you know, relatively unusual in in well in world culture you know why would we why would we want to have this alarming subject so as a comforting midwinter thing in particular and if you were to boil it down um roger do you think that so i found your book fascinating and particularly the stuff about religion and ghosts, sort of linking the two. I mean, you have a line in your book about belief in ghosts as a sort of decayed form of religion in a secular age or something. But you talk a lot about the influence of the Reformation, so breaking with the Catholic Church and then the Civil War and so on. And do you think it's because of the Reformation that England specifically has this tradition of ghost stories and so many kind of monks
而且我们似乎有一种特定的观念，认为鬼故事是令人宽慰的，这在世界文化中是相对罕见的。你知道，为什么我们会想要把这个令人不安的主题作为一种令人宽慰的仲冬事物呢？特别是如果你要把它归纳一下，嗯，罗杰，你认为……我发现你的书非常引人入胜，特别是关于宗教和鬼魂将两者联系起来的内容。我的意思是，你的书中有一行字，说对鬼魂的信仰是世俗时代宗教的一种衰退形式之类的。但你谈到了很多宗教改革的影响，即与天主教会决裂，然后是内战等等。你认为正是因为宗教改革，英国才有了这种鬼故事的传统，以及这么多僧侣
and nuns and sort of haunted Jesuitical figures and stuff like that. Yes, the walled-up monks and so forth, they're all essentially regency, what I call off-the-shelf ghosts. And it's the same with headless carriages and headless horsemen and that sort of thing. And again, with acephaly, the headlessness, you can go almost straight back to, you know, the saints, the, what do you call them, cephalophores, the headless saints,
和修女，还有那种闹鬼的耶稣会士形象之类的东西吗？是的，那些被封在墙里的僧侣等等，本质上都是摄政时期的，我称之为“现成的”鬼魂。无头马车和无头骑士也是如此。关于无头（acephaly），你可以直接追溯到圣徒，也就是所谓的“持头者”（cephalophores），即那些无头的圣徒，
which is a long tradition, as you both know. And I was very interested as to, you know, Anne Boleyn being quite a, I mean, she's seen in popular culture as a sort of, you know, a bit of a sort of dizzy creature. But as far as I understand, she was quite a fearsome Protestant believer. And the idea that she would come back on an anniversary,
正如你们俩所知，这是一个悠久的传统。我对安妮·博林（Anne Boleyn）非常感兴趣，我的意思是，她在流行文化中被视为一个有点头晕目眩的生物。但据我所知，她是一个相当可怕的新教信徒。她会在周年纪念日回来的想法，
a bit like a saint, she was almost like a saint's day, these anniversaries, with her head. And where was she coming from? Was she coming from purgatory? Yeah. And if she was, that means that her whole belief system, if she was coming from purgatory, was incorrect. There was a while where to believe in ghosts
有点像圣徒，这些周年纪念日几乎就像圣徒纪念日一样，带着她的头。她是从哪里来的？她是从炼狱来的吗？是的。如果她是，那就意味着如果她是从炼狱来的，那么她的整个信仰体系就是错误的。有一段时间，相信鬼魂
marked you out as a Catholic, which was a dangerous business. Well, so Roger, I mean, obviously there's an echo there of perhaps the most famous ghost in English literature, which is the ghost of Hamlet's father. Yes. And that sense that Hamlet, who studies at Wittenberg and therefore presumably is a good Protestant, has as a father a ghost who's in purgatory
会让你被标记为天主教徒，这是一件危险的事情。那么，罗杰，我的意思是，显然这里有一个回响，也许是英国文学中最著名的鬼魂，也就是哈姆雷特父亲的鬼魂。是的。那种哈姆雷特在维滕贝格学习，因此大概是一个好的新教徒，却有一个身处炼狱的父亲作为鬼魂，
and who therefore presumably is Catholic. I mean, that's a kind of buried element of the play, isn't it? Yes, and there's a lot of theories that Shakespeare was a secret Catholic and so forth, which I find quite slightly convincing, in the same way that maybe M.R. James had high church leadings that he wanted to conceal from his father, which is why he didn't become a clergyman. And you notice that a lot of M.R. James' ghosts are to do
因此大概是天主教徒。我的意思是，这是剧本中一个被埋藏的元素，不是吗？是的，有很多理论认为莎士比亚是秘密天主教徒等等，我觉得这有点令人信服，就像M.R.詹姆斯（M.R. James）可能有着他想向父亲隐瞒的高教会倾向，这就是为什么他没有成为牧师的原因。你会注意到M.R.詹姆斯的许多鬼魂都与
with pre-Protestant guardian spirits and so forth. Yes, so M.R. James, for those listeners who don't know, is the sort of the supreme exponent of the classic ghost story, isn't he? He's writing at the sort of – when's he writing? Early 20th century, I suppose. But his stories are always backward-looking, aren't they? And they have that gothic element, which I get the impression from your book that you think the gothic element in i get i get the impression from your book that you think you you think the
前新教的守护神等等有关。是的，所以M.R.詹姆斯，对于那些不知道的听众来说，是经典鬼故事的最高代表，不是吗？他写作的时期是……他是什么时候写作的？我想是20世纪初。但他的故事总是向后看的，不是吗？它们有那种哥特式元素，我从你的书中得到的印象是，你认为哥特式元素在……我从你的书中得到的印象是，你认为
gothic element in ghost stories well well yeah i'm not going to put words in your mouth and say that you think it's fraudulent but that you think you talk about things being folkloric yes um which you generally mean i don't get the sense that you mean that approvingly and you think that folkloric elements of a ghost story mean that it's as it were true but you think that that's kind of people have brought a lot of baggage to the story if you like oh yes no i don't mean folkloric elements of a ghost story mean that it's, as it were, true. But you think that that's kind of people have brought a lot of baggage to the story, if you like. Oh, yes. No, I don't mean folkloric disparagingly at all.
鬼故事中的哥特式元素……嗯，是的，我不会把话塞进你嘴里说你认为它是欺诈，但你谈到事物是“民俗的”（folkloric）。是的，嗯，你通常是指……我并不觉得你是赞同地这么说，你认为鬼故事的民俗元素意味着它在某种程度上是真实的，但你认为人们为这个故事带来了很多包袱，如果你愿意的话。哦，是的，不，我完全不是贬义地使用“民俗”这个词。
I'm in some sense a folklorist. You know, I think you tend to be with ghost belief a bit more on the folkloric side or the science side. And the science side has sort of reached a kind of cul-de-sac for one reason or the other. It was very active for over 100 years. And I think we're now much more seeing ghost stories and things as constructions of all sorts of complicated social mores.
在某种意义上，我是一个民俗学家。你知道，我认为在鬼魂信仰方面，你往往更倾向于民俗学或科学这一边。而科学这一边因为某种原因已经进入了一个死胡同。它活跃了100多年。我认为我们现在更多地将鬼故事视为各种复杂社会习俗的建构。
And I also talk in the book about the British class aspect of ghosts. But going back to the Catholicism thing, I mean, you've got the birth of the castle of Otranto and Walpole is round about the whole time all of the Catholic Emancipation Act and so forth were trundling through. There were several of them. And you can see this and this, you know, the Gordon riots and this genuine alarm that Catholicism was like crawling back out of the ground, you know,
我在书中也谈到了鬼魂的英国阶级层面。但回到天主教的问题上，我的意思是，你有《奥特朗托城堡》（The Castle of Otranto）的诞生，而沃波尔（Walpole）所处的时代正是《天主教解放法案》等等正在推进的时候。有好几项这样的法案。你可以看到这一点，你知道，戈登暴动（Gordon riots）以及这种认为天主教正像从地下爬回来的真实警报，你知道，
and would bring ghosts with it. And, you know, that's why you get these sort of spectral and satanic monks in Gothic literature. M.R. James, who's sort of my hero, very much disapproved of a lot of Gothic literature for one reason or the other. He thought it a bit distasteful and he what's interesting about mr james is he's routinely held up as our greatest ghost story writer of fictional ghost stories and yet what he does is not actually traditional ghosts at all they're either these sort of dead alive medieval type walking dead who's a definite thing uh that and the animated corpse or or as i say these kind of guardian spirits as a result of sort of versions of black magic and occult practice
并且会随之带来鬼魂。你知道，这就是为什么你在哥特文学中会看到这些幽灵般的、撒旦般的僧侣。M.R.詹姆斯，他是我的英雄，他非常不赞成许多哥特文学。他认为这有点令人反感，而关于M.R.詹姆斯有趣的是，他通常被认为是我们要么最伟大的虚构鬼故事作家，然而他所做的实际上根本不是传统的鬼魂。它们要么是那种死而复生的中世纪僵尸，这是一个明确的事物，或者是那种动画尸体，或者正如我所说，这些作为黑魔法和神秘实践版本的守护神。
and so they're really not at all you know lonely spirits and things like that they're quite they're quite fearsome and and inhuman and unpleasant so before we start to look at in more detail at the way that the british understanding of ghosts has evolved from the reformation and onwards can we just broaden the camera back out again because you you mentioned medieval ghosts yeah that that they are kind of subtly different to the ones that we now know and then of course before that there's the example of the classical ghost and from you know the ones that we now know. And then, of course, before that, there's the example of the classical ghost. And from the story that Dominic narrated at the head of the show, you've got clanking chains. You've got people who need to be buried. So there are clearly elements there that do feed into the kind of the mainstream. And also the Greeks and the Romans thought that ghosts
所以它们真的根本不是孤独的灵魂之类的东西，它们相当可怕、非人且令人不快。所以在我们开始更详细地研究英国人对鬼魂的理解如何从宗教改革及以后演变之前，我们能把镜头再拉远一点吗？因为你提到了中世纪的鬼魂，是的，它们与我们现在所知的那些微妙地不同，当然在那之前还有古典鬼魂的例子。从多米尼克在节目开头讲述的故事中，你有叮当作响的锁链。你有需要被安葬的人。所以那里显然有一些元素确实融入了主流。而且希腊人和罗马人也认为鬼魂
vanished on cock crows and that they appear at midnight and at midday and kind of various elements like that so how different are say classical ghosts to the ghosts that we recognize today and to what extent do those classical stories have an influence on the ghost stories we know it if you go all the way back to this you know Sumerian dead and things that what ghosts were, were again sort of half demonic. They weren't really quite people and they weren't really quite ghosts as we understand it. And this idea of the hungry dead or the dead being unhappy about the way that they'd been buried,
在公鸡打鸣时消失，它们在午夜和正午出现，诸如此类。那么古典鬼魂与我们今天所认识的鬼魂有多大不同？这些古典故事在多大程度上影响了我们所知的鬼故事？如果你一直追溯到苏美尔人的死者等等，鬼魂本质上又是半恶魔化的。它们并不完全是人，也不完全是我们所理解的鬼魂。这种饥饿的死者，或者死者对他们被埋葬的方式感到不满的想法，
which is what you get in the Greek story you mentioned earlier, is like an abrogation of burial procedure. It's very problematic for all of the archaic ghosts but as soon as ghosts are seen as sort of people a bit like you and i all that which so that didn't really happen until totally until the 1950s where ghosts were just seen as people uh they you know you get this gradual procession of this archaic idea of the troubled dead, the unburied dead, who wanted proper observance made, proper burial made. who were really just being prepared for the afterlife and were coming back to warn people to live better lives and to be, well, just to lead better lives, really. And they were often warnings of their imminent death and they need to get their act together, that sort of thing.
也就是你在前面提到的希腊故事中所得到的，就像是对埋葬程序的废除。这对所有古老的鬼魂来说都是非常麻烦的。但一旦鬼魂被视为像你我一样的人，这种情况直到1950年代才完全发生，那时鬼魂才被视为人。你知道，你会看到这种古老的“困扰的死者”、“未被安葬的死者”的逐渐演变，他们想要得到适当的仪式，适当的安葬。他们实际上只是在为来世做准备，并回来警告人们过更好的生活，嗯，只是过更好的生活。他们往往是死亡临近的警告，他们需要振作起来，诸如此类。
Because my sense of, say, Roman ghosts, and for starters, they don't really have a word equivalent to our ghost. I mean, they have kind of various different qualities of shade that might appear. Some are ancestral ghosts, some are more malign. And then the kind of very weird one. So the weird one I remember is Brutus, the murderer of Caesar on the eve of the Battle of Philippi, which he will end up committing suicide, kind of seeing himself and saying, you know, I am your, what is it? I kind of, I am your fate.
因为我对罗马鬼魂的理解是，首先，他们并没有一个等同于我们“鬼魂”（ghost）的词。我的意思是，他们有各种不同性质的阴影可能会出现。有些是祖先的鬼魂，有些更具恶意。还有那种非常奇怪的。我记得那个奇怪的是布鲁图斯（Brutus），凯撒的刺客，在腓立比战役前夕，他最终会自杀，他看到自己并说，你知道，我是你的，是什么来着？我，我是你的命运。
I have come to warn you. And it's kind of a ghost, but it's not quite, is it? And I suppose you have the sense that we're dealing with with things that kind of look familiar but but are strange in ways that we can't quite put our fingers on well that story is quite interesting because one of the great revelations of the society of cycle research which was this incredibly august body created in 1882 full of prime ministers and poet laureates and uh you know extremely eminent scientists, some of whom went on to win Nobel Prizes.
我来警告你。这算是一种鬼魂，但又不完全是，对吧？我想你有一种感觉，我们正在处理那些看起来很熟悉，但在某些方面又很奇怪，以至于我们无法完全确定它们是什么的东西。嗯，那个故事非常有趣，因为心灵研究协会（Society for Psychical Research）的伟大启示之一，这是一个成立于1882年、极其庄严的机构，充满了首相和桂冠诗人，以及你知道，极其杰出的科学家，其中一些人后来获得了诺贝尔奖。
And one of the first things they discovered is called phantasms of the living. The most common ghosts were ghosts of living people, and that people were still alive. And this really threw the cat among the pigeons, the idea of what ghost could possibly be um surely if they were still alive then they weren't ghosts in the classical sense there was some kind of other emanation uh possibly to do with the science as let as yet unknown which is where this whole science trajectory kind of began uh and sort of ended relatively recently
他们发现的第一件事被称为“生者的幻象”（phantasms of the living）。最常见的鬼魂是活人的鬼魂，而这些人还活着。这真的在鸽群中投下了一只猫（引起了混乱），关于鬼魂可能是什么的想法。嗯，如果他们还活着，那么他们就不是古典意义上的鬼魂，而是某种其他的流溢物，可能与某种尚未被科学所知的科学有关，这就是整个科学轨迹开始的地方，并且在最近才相对结束。
i guess looking for for scientific you looking for ghosts that can be explained scientifically, I mean, that is as much a reflection of our age as a Catholic ghost in Protestant England or a Sumerian ghost in Sumeria. Also, I mean, battle ghosts and battlefields are famous sites for ghosts. It's like the Battle of Edge Hill and so forth. It was seen in the night sky, you know, afterwards and so forth.
我想寻找科学解释的鬼魂，我的意思是，这和新教英国的天主教鬼魂或苏美尔的苏美尔鬼魂一样，都是我们时代的反映。另外，我的意思是，战场鬼魂和战场是著名的鬼魂出没地。就像埃奇山战役（Battle of Edge Hill）等等。它在夜空中被看到，你知道，事后等等。我认为这种关于预言、王权和伟人的想法都是那种浪漫权力混合体的一部分。我有一个听众的问题，正好接上汤姆关于古典鬼魂的观点。我想我们现在有时间来做这个。我们也会给汤姆一个机会谈谈他最喜欢的主题。所以这是关于《新约》，耶稣说，他回来了，他说，我不是鬼魂。有没有人认为耶稣实际上是鬼魂的传统？
And this idea of prophecy and, you know, kingship and great men is all part of that romantic mix of power, I think. I've got a question from one of the listeners asked, just picking up on Tom's point about classical ghosts. I think we have a good time to do this. We'll also give Tom a chance to talk about his favourite subjects. So it's about the New Testament where Jesus says, he comes back and he says, I'm not a ghost. Is there any tradition of people thinking that Jesus was actually a ghost?
实际上，你知道，那个在受难后出现的人实际上不是重生的基督，而只是一个普通的、普通的犹太鬼魂。是的，我想汤姆比我更了解这一点。但是是的，我的意思是，我想你进入了关于三位一体和圣灵（Holy Ghost）的整个问题，以及它如何契合，这总是受到其他宗教的一些嘲笑，在某种程度上，什么是圣灵等等。但是是的，关于耶稣复活，
That actually, you know, the fellow who pitches up after the crucifixion is actually not the reborn Christ, but is just a bog-standard, just an ordinary kind of Jewish ghost. Yes, I think Tom will know more about this than I do. But yes, I mean, I suppose you get into the whole matter of the Trinity and the Holy Ghost and how that fits in, which has always been the result of some mockery from other religions, to what extent, what is the Holy Ghost and so forth. But yes, as far as the Jesus resurrection,
我真的不知道该说什么。他是鬼魂吗？但他同时是一切。嗯，我猜，我的意思是，我猜那种坚持，你知道，托马斯触摸他的伤口。正是如此。身体的物理性。是的。是设定在一个世界背景下，在这个世界中，
I don't really know what to say about that. Is he a ghost? But he's all things at once. Well, I guess, I mean, I guess the insistence that, you know, Thomas feel his wounds. Exactly. The physicality of the body. Yes. Is set against a background of a world in which it is pretty much
死者可以复活几乎是理所当然的。你只是有这个，你知道在古典世界中，你只是有这种令人难以置信的各种幽灵，每一种可以想象的类型，所以我觉得对于福音书的作者来说，坚持他，你知道，复活的基督不是这些各种幽灵中的一个，是非常非常重要的。是的，我的意思是，有趣的是，那里显然有致命的伤害，然而他却以某种方式被维持住了。也许这就是基础，
taken for granted that the dead can rise up. And you just have this, you know in in in the classical world you just have this incredible array of specters every conceivable kind and so it's really really important i think for the for the writers of the gospel to insist that he you know the risen christ is not one of these various specters yes and I mean, what's interesting is there's clearly the mortal damage there, and yet he is somehow sustained. And maybe this is the basis for
M.R.詹姆斯所钟爱的那个伟大的中世纪传统，即行尸走肉，那些走动的、某种程度上……但你是对的，我的意思是，耶稣显然是一个特例，所以你不能真正从耶稣身上推断出普遍的鬼魂信仰。我认为这是一个完美的节点，也许可以快速休息一下。如果我们在谈论鬼魂传说，耶稣确实是一个特例。也许当我们回来时，我们可以看看一些最伟大的鬼故事，任何对这个主题有哪怕最模糊了解的人都会知道的鬼故事，鲍利教区长住宅（Bawley Rectory）等等。
this great medieval tradition which M. R. James loved of the walking dead, the ambulatory people who were sort of... But you're right, I mean, Jesus was obviously a special case, so you can't really extrapolate on general ghost belief from Jesus. I think that's a perfect note, perhaps, on which to take a quick break. Jesus was indeed a special case, I guess, if we're talking ghost lore. And maybe when we come back, we could look at some of the greatest ghost stories, ghost stories that anyone with even the vaguest familiarity with the subject will know, Bawley Rectory and so on.
因为你对那些经典故事的重述确实非常了不起。所以，伙计们，别走开。值得留下来听听。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
Because your retelling of those classic stories is really quite something. So, guys, don't go away. It's worth hanging around for. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在和罗杰·克拉克谈论鬼魂，在前半部分胡乱聊了一些罗马鬼魂和耶稣之后，我怎么能深入探讨一些英国那种伟大的经典鬼故事呢？
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about ghosts with Roger Clarke and having sort of faffed around with some Roman ghosts and with Jesus in the first half, how can I get stuck into some of the great classic ghost stories of sort of English,
英国民俗类的鬼魂传统？所以，罗杰，为什么我们不从你在书中真正开篇的故事之一开始呢？那是那座被闹鬼闹到死去的房子，对吧？它叫什么？欣顿？欣顿安普纳（Hinton Ampner）。欣顿安普纳。我想它现在是国家信托基金（National Trust）的房子了，对吧？确实是。
of the English folkloric kind of ghost tradition? So, Roger, why don't we start with one of the stories that you kick off with, really, in your book. It's the house that was haunted to death, isn't it? What's it called? Hinton? Hinton Ampner. Hinton Ampner. I think it's a National Trust house now, isn't it? It is indeed.
那里有一座相对现代的房子。它被烧毁过好几次。那是伊钦河（River Itchen）到达的地方。是的。弗格尔·沙基（Fergal Sharkey）带我去那里走过。非常令人毛骨悚然。是的。他很棒。
It's got a relatively modern house there. It's burnt down several times. It's where the River Itchen arrives. Yes. I got taken there by Fergal Sharkey to walk it. Very creepy it was too. Yes. He's amazing.
我在推特上关注他。是的，它真的被拆除了。它被认为闹鬼太严重，以至于无法居住。它被拆除了。它被认为闹鬼太严重，以至于无法居住，所以被拆除了。我的意思是，但欣顿的一个有趣案例，一个有趣的方面是，有大量关于它的书面家庭文件，是由那些绝非傻瓜的人记录的。对我来说，它有任何鬼魂案例中最好的证人之一，
I follow him on Twitter. Yes, it was really knocked down. It was considered to be so haunted it was unliveable in. And it was knocked down. It was considered to be so haunted that it was unliveable, and it was knocked down. I mean, but one of the interesting cases, one of the interesting aspects of Hinton is that there was a huge amount of written down family documents about it by people who were really not fools. And it has, for me, one of the best witnesses of any ghost case there,
那就是圣文森特勋爵（Lord St. Vincent），后来成为圣文森特勋爵，那位著名的海军上将。是的。基本上，你知道，胜利号（HMS Victory）是他的船等等。他是那位平定斯皮特黑德兵变（Spithead Mutiny）等等的著名人物。他绝对是那种务实的海军权威的精髓。他只是……
which is Lord St. Vincent, who later became Lord St. Vincent, who was the famous admiral. Yes. And basically, you know, HMS Victory was his ship and so forth. He was the famous man who put down the Spithead Mutiny and so forth. He was absolutely the essence of no-nonsense, you know, naval authority. And he was just...
直到他生命的尽头，显然，每当提到那个鬼魂时，他都会勃然大怒，因为他亲身经历过，而且无法解释。所以给我们讲讲这个故事。给那些不知道的听众讲讲这个故事的一部分。所以在1760年代左右，这个叫玛丽·里基茨（Mary Ricketts）的女人带着她的孩子们在汉普郡租了一间房子，然后去了那里。
And to the end of his days, apparently, he flew into a rage whenever the ghost was mentioned because he experienced it firsthand and could not explain it. So give us the story. Give us some of the story for those listeners who don't know it. So in the sort of 1760s, this woman called Mary Ricketts rented a house with her children in Hampshire and went there.
她的丈夫在西印度群岛出差，所以她基本上是独自一人。她带了自己的仆人去那里。那是一座相当古老、破败的房子。很快，麻烦就开始了，有很多砰砰作响的门，看起来好像有人进进出出房子，没人能弄清楚发生了什么，伦敦来的仆人都离开了，留住仆人成了问题，
And her husband was sort of away on business in the West Indies, so she was very much on her own. She took her own servants down there. It was a pretty old, decayed house. And pretty soon, nuisance started, which was lots of banging doors, and it seemed like people were coming in and out of the house and nobody could work out what was going on, and the London servants all left, and there were problems keeping servants,
然后他们贴出了一张悬赏通知，因为他们认为，你知道，他们提供了相当多的钱，就像一年的劳工工资，农村劳工工资，以获取关于谁在闯入房子的信息。它就这样不断地升级。房子的周围出现了男人的幻影，然后是女人匆忙跑过的声音。我们拥有的是玛丽·里基茨的一手日记记录，它存放在大英图书馆。
and then they put up a reward notice because they thought, you know, they're offering quite a lot of money, like a year's labourer's wage, rural labouring wage, for information on who was breaking into the house. And it just sort of cascaded on and on and on. And these apparitions of a man were seen around the house and then the sound of a woman rushing through. And what we have is a first-hand, almost diary account from Mary Ricketts, which is lodged in the British Library.
我坐在那里读着这份日记，通常是逐日记录，关于试图处理正在发生的事情。她基本上是独自一人，并且非常害怕她的孩子们最终会看到鬼魂。所以这与现代鬼故事相反，在现代鬼故事中，是孩子们看到鬼魂而成年人看不到，在这里，成年人试图保护孩子们免受鬼魂的伤害。她关于
And I've sat there reading this day by day, often day by day, account of trying to deal with what was going on. It's pretty much on her own and being terrified that her children will eventually see the ghost. So it's the opposite of a modern ghost story, where it's the children who see the ghosts and the adults don't here the adult is trying to shield that you know the children from the ghost and she a bit about
玛丽·里基茨，你知道，她是一位受过极高教育的女性，拥有强大的智力，受到许多神职人员的高度评价，他们来到她身边提供帮助。最终他们不得不离开那座房子，他们无法住在里面。他们回去后，我不知道他们经历了所有这些可怕的经历，还有正午的鬼魂，在白天，门被砰砰地关上。我的意思是，你读到这些，你会看到她的笔迹在恶化，这真的很引人注目。她最终逃到了温彻斯特的主教宫，在那里她从她的一些神职朋友那里得到了庇护，我想这就是这个故事最终被传达给本森主教（Bishop Benson），坎特伯雷大主教，然后他告诉了亨利·詹姆斯（Henry James），后者把它变成了，在我看来，
mary ricketts you know she was extremely well educated uh woman with a powerful intellect who was very highly thought of by a lot of members of the clergy who kind of came to her aid and eventually they had to leave the house they couldn't they couldn't live in it and they went back after i don't know where they were all these awful experiences and midday ghost goes in the middle of the day and the door being bangs and i mean you read about it and you see her handwriting deteriorate it's really quite striking and she eventually fled to the bishop's palace in in winchester where she was given sanctuary by some of her clerical friends and that's how i think the story got eventually relayed to bishop Benson, the Archbishop of Canterbury, who then told it to Henry James, who turned it into, in my view,
它是《螺丝在拧紧》（Turn of the Screw）的源头故事。我最近刚发现一件事，M.R.詹姆斯在本科生时期，实际上在1880年代去拜访过本森主教，并与同一位本森主教一起度过了圣诞节，他在成为坎特伯雷大主教之前是主教。我有一种可爱的想法，也许M.R.詹姆斯被告知了这个故事，
it's the source story for Turn of the Screw. And I just actually found out something recently, that M.R. James, as an undergraduate, actually went to stay with Bishop Benson in the sort of 1880s and spent Christmas with the same Bishop Benson, who was then bishop before he became Archbishop at Canterbury. And I have this sort of lovely idea that maybe M.R. James was told this story
也许他有这个故事的优先权，但他拒绝了。两个人都叫詹姆斯，这太神奇了。是的，是的。我不禁认为他的鬼故事《失落的心》（Lost Hearts）可能有一些《螺丝在拧紧》的埋藏元素。但我真的很想解开这个谜团。对我来说，那是一个巨大的谜团。本森主教讲的这个故事是什么？
and maybe he got first dibs on this story and turned it down. It's amazing that two people called James. Yes, yes. I can't help thinking that elements of his ghost story called Lost Hearts may have sort of some buried elements of Turn of the Screw. But I really wanted to crack the mystery. For me, that was a big mystery. What was this story that Bishop Benson told?
那么到底发生了什么？因为在英国内战中，切里顿战役（Battle of Cheriton）基本上是在欣顿安普纳的土地上进行的。嗯，这种闹鬼有一种令人难以置信的音景。这是一个非常、非常吵闹的闹鬼。所以我认为那里确实有战斗的声音，我认为它几乎传到了房子的窗户和门口。就像它真的在重演一样。
And so what was going on? Because there is the Battle of Cheriton in the English Civil War that is fought basically on the grounds of Hinton Amner. Well, there's this incredible sort of soundscape of this haunting. It's a very, very noisy haunting. And so I think there was noise really of the battle, which I think came up almost to the windows and the door of the house. And it was like it was being replayed, really.
但这并不能解释人们去……我的意思是，没有什么能解释它。但通常当你闹鬼时，会有人想出一些故事来解释为什么会有这些存在，或者发生了什么。有什么故事吗？是的，有各种关于家庭成员和高级仆人之间有私情的故事。又是《螺丝在拧紧》那种东西。
But that wouldn't explain people going, I mean, nothing would explain it. But usually when you have hauntings, there's somebody comes up with some story to explain why there are these presences or what's going on. Is there any story? Yes, there were various stories about that there'd been an affair between a member of the household and a senior servant. Again, turn of the screw sort of thing.
而且他们可能就是被看到的幻影。但我认为这就是你所说的某种……而且它可能，它们可能就是被看到的幻影。但我认为这就是你所说的某种……多重闹鬼，有很多不同的鬼魂在做不同的事情，你知道。因为这很不寻常，它不完全是一个骚灵（poltergeist）故事，对吧？有砰砰声，
And that they were probably the apparitions seen. But I think this is what you'd call a sort of a. And that it was probably, they were probably the apparitions seen. But I think this is what you'd call a sort of a multiple haunting, that there are a lot of different ghosts doing different things, you know. Because it's unusual that there's, it's not quite a poltergeist story, is it? There's a banging,
但没有东西被扔。我说的对吗？而孩子们，正如你所说，通常在古典的那种，嗯，我们认为的那种经典鬼故事中，孩子们能看到鬼魂，或者他们被附身，或者他们以某种方式参与其中。
but there's not stuff being thrown. Am I right? And the children who are often, as you say, almost always in the classical kind of, well, what we think of as the kind of classic ghost story, the children can see the ghost or they're possessed or they're somehow involved.
但孩子们完全不知道。这就是正在发生的事情吗？对我来说，这是一个非常有趣的转折。它与好莱坞讲述故事的方式完全相反。它实际上更有趣。只是这个陷入困境的女人的想法，我认为它就像一个房屋入侵故事，就像一个暴力房屋入侵的版本，我认为这真的有点像泰德沃斯（Tedworth）
But the children are completely oblivious. Is that what's going on? For me, that's such an interesting twist. It's completely opposite of how Hollywood would tell a story. It's actually much more interesting. And just this idea of this embattled woman and i think i think it's a sort of it's sort of like a house invasion story it's like an aversion of a violent house invasion and i think that's it's really the sort of a bit like the tedworth
鼓手（Drummer）的故事，我想，汤姆在附近长大，对此非常了解。是的，所以那是另一个骚灵。而骚灵，我很感兴趣。我记得对吗，马丁·路德（Martin Luther）是第一个使用“骚灵”（poltergeist）这个词的人？他被认为创造了这个复合词，是的。所以他不仅引发了宗教改革，他还想出了骚灵这个词。
drama i suppose uh which tom knows all about having grown up near there yes so so that's another poltergeist. And a poltergeist, I was intrigued. Do I remember this right, that Martin Luther is the first person to use the word poltergeist? He is supposed to have made the compound word, yes. So not only did he cause the Reformation, but he came up with poltergeist too.
所以这真是一系列成就。当德国和骚灵之间有一种奇怪的联系时……所以这真是一系列成就，当德国和骚灵之间有一种奇怪的联系时，无论如何，在第二次世界大战之前，人们说，嗯，当然纳粹主义、法西斯主义之所以存在，是因为它全是关于嘈杂、未成形的精神力量，当然它会来自德国，因为它就像骚灵的中心。骚灵在某种程度上似乎是最难解释的故事，但也可能是因为这个原因，它们最引人入胜地向宗教潮流投射了一面镜子。你在17世纪的鬼故事中看到了这一点，
So that's quite a roster of achievements. When there is a strange connection between Germany and poltergeist too so that's that's quite a roster of achievements and then when there is a strange connection between germany and poltergeist anyway and so you get before world war two people saying well of course nazism fascism is there because it's all about noisy inchoate spiritual forces and of course it would come from germany because it's like poltergeist central. Poltergeists in a way seem that the strangest stories to explain, but also the ones perhaps because of that, that hold a mirror up most intriguingly to kind of religious currents. And you see that in the 17th century gay stories,
像泰德沃斯鼓手那样的骚灵故事。是的。你在这一篇中也看到了，而且你在……也许是最引人入胜的故事中也看到了，因为它基本上我们知道它是假的，那就是科克巷鬼魂（Cock Lane ghost）的故事。是的，它不仅有别人，还有约翰逊博士（Dr. Johnson）。所以你能给我们讲讲那个吗？因为那是一个伟大的故事。是的。在1760年代，一对夫妇没地方住，他们和科克巷的这家人住在一起。然后他们和科克巷的那家人闹翻了，妻子去世了。突然间，这个消息传开了，说妻子在闹鬼，敲击着谴责她丈夫的声音，
poltergeist stories like Tedworth Drummer. Yeah. And you see it in this one um and you also see it in um perhaps the most fascinating of all the stories because it basically we know that it's a fake which is the story of the cock lane ghost yes which features none other than dr johnson so can you just tell us a bit about that because that that's a great story. Yes. So in the 1760s as well, a chap and his wife had nowhere to stay and they stayed with this family in Cock Lane. And then they fell out with the family in Cock Lane and the wife died. And suddenly this news came around that the wife was haunting the house and tapping out a condemnation of her husband,
说她丈夫谋杀了她。现在，丈夫来自受过教育的绅士阶层，而他住的那家人的帕森斯（Parsons）一家，基本上只是与经营附近的圣塞普尔克教堂（St Sepulchre's）有关的工人阶级。然后他意识到他可以收费，而且这一切都围绕着两个小女孩，她们躺在床上，这些敲击声就会传来，
that her husband had murdered her. Now, the husband was from an educated gentleman class, and the chap whose house he was in, the Parsons family, were just basically working-class people associated with running the nearby church, St Sepulchre's. And he then realised that he could charge money, and it was all centred around the two little girls, and they'd lie in bed and these knocks would come,
他们想出了一定数量的敲击声代表“是”，一次代表“否”。事实上，我想是反过来的，很不寻常。后来，它变成了一次代表“否”。人们会过来，突然间，因为有一种相当狂热的气氛，因为有很多刚创办的报纸，新闻纸和报纸标题有了巨大的扩张，它变成了一个巨大的丑闻，人群聚集在一起希望听到鬼魂，然后
and they worked out certain amounts of raps for yes and one for no. In fact, I think it was the other way around, unusually. Later on, it became one for no. And people would come round and suddenly, because there was a rather feverish atmosphere going on, because there was a lot of recently launched newspapers, there was a huge expansion in newsprint and newspaper titles it became a sort of big scandal and people crowds would gather hoping to hear the ghost and then
王室成员会坐着马车出现来听鬼魂，它变成了一个丑闻，因为他们必须弄清楚，我们要把它当作谋杀案来处理吗？发生了什么？所以它被调查了。约翰逊博士是调查它的团队之一。很快整件事就破灭了，父亲是个酒鬼。这基本上是一个出了问题的酒吧笑话。但每个人都以为他们知道。这是一个完全的阴谋论。
members of the royal family would turn up like in their coach to hear the ghost and and it became a sort of scandal because they had to work out, are we going to treat this as a murder story and what's going on? And so it was sort of investigated. Dr. Johnson was on one of the teams investigating it. And pretty soon the whole thing fell apart, that the father was a drunk. And it was basically a sort of pub joke that went wrong. But everyone thought that they knew. It was a complete conspiracy theory.
皇室成员会乘着马车前来听鬼魂说话，这成了一桩丑闻，因为他们不得不弄清楚，我们该把它当作谋杀案来处理吗？到底发生了什么？于是这件事受到了一定程度的调查。约翰逊博士是调查小组的成员之一。很快，整件事就破灭了，原来那个父亲是个酒鬼。这基本上就是一个搞砸了的酒吧笑话。但每个人都以为自己知道真相。这完全是一个阴谋论。
Everyone thought they knew what was really going on. There was a very sort of feverish feeling. There was a lot of drunkenness. This is really a ghost story about the effect of drink. It's about gin, isn't it? They're all drinking gin. They're all absolutely bladdered on gin so and and and in fact i discovered subsequent to writing this book there was also another scandal as a sort of uh in the pub another few doors down just a little
每个人都以为自己知道真相。当时有一种非常狂热的情绪。喝醉酒的人很多。这其实是一个关于酒精影响的鬼故事。是关于杜松子酒，对吧？他们都在喝杜松子酒。他们都喝得烂醉如泥，事实上，我在写这本书之后发现，在几扇门外的一家酒吧里，还发生了另一桩丑闻，就在稍微
bit earlier which was to do with a kind of gay sex scandal. And so that had also happened on the same street just really months earlier. So everyone was just going crazy. The Lord Mayor got involved. There was eventually a court case. It's a shame that it turned out to be a fake because I do love the idea of Dr. Johnson as a kind of agent moulder.
早一点的时候，那是一桩同性性丑闻。所以那件事也发生在同一条街上，就在几个月前。所以每个人都快疯了。市长也介入了。最终还闹上了法庭。可惜后来发现那是假的，因为我真的很喜欢约翰逊博士作为某种特工塑造者的想法。
Yes. Investigating ghosts. There's a great series of novels in that or a sort of TV series, Dr. Johnson Ghost Hunter. Yes, heer. Yes. He's investigating ghosts. There's a great series of novels in that, or a TV series. Dr. Johnson, Ghost Hunter. Yes, he'd be very... Waiting to be written. Well, there's this fantastic scene where he goes down...
是的。调查鬼魂。这其中有一系列很棒的小说，或者说电视连续剧，《约翰逊博士：捉鬼敢死队》。是的，就是这样。是的。他在调查鬼魂。这其中有一系列很棒的小说，或者说电视连续剧。《约翰逊博士：捉鬼敢死队》。是的，他会非常……等着被写出来。嗯，有一个非常精彩的场景，他走下去……
I mean, I live in Old Street, not far from Clerkenwell. There's this marvellous scene of him going down the staircase into the crypt of the church there. I think it's St Anne's, I'm not sure. And because the ghost has promised to knock on the lid of her coffin in the crypt and they're all there craning to hear and nothing happens. And interestingly, that area is also almost certainly
我是说，我住在老街，离克勒肯维尔不远。有一个很棒的场景，他走下楼梯进入那里的教堂地穴。我想是圣安妮教堂，我不确定。因为那个鬼魂承诺会敲击地穴里她棺材的盖子，他们都在那里伸长脖子听，结果什么也没发生。有趣的是，那个地区也几乎可以肯定是
where Swedenborg had his vision. It's also, it's just around the corner from St uh saint bartholomew the great the parish church that was founded originally as a priory by rahir supposedly the um the jester of um of henry the first and apparently um some workmen in the 19th century were working on his tomb and one of the workmen stole his sandal and ever since rahir appears on the day that his sandal was stolen, demanding it back. So I throw that out. Tom, I've heard that story in a churchyard in Moscow.
斯威登堡产生幻觉的地方。它也就在圣巴塞洛缪大教堂的拐角处，那座教区教堂最初是由拉希尔建立的，据说是亨利一世的弄臣，显然，19世纪有一些工人在修理他的坟墓时，其中一个工人偷了他的凉鞋，从那以后，拉希尔就在他凉鞋被偷的那一天出现，要求把它要回来。所以我提一下这个。汤姆，我在莫斯科的一个教堂墓地也听过那个故事。
And it's one of those portable stories. So Stalin had... I'm glad you've debunked Tom in front of all our listeners. It's great. Anyway, can we just... Me and Dr. Johnson both. Can we just unpack that story? No, that was... Yeah, so...
这是一种流传很广的故事。所以斯大林有……我很高兴你在我们所有听众面前揭穿了汤姆。太棒了。总之，我们能……我和约翰逊博士都……我们能剖析一下那个故事吗？不，那是……是的，所以……
The cock lane story. Because there's a couple of elements of that that come up again and again in your book about ghost stories. One of them is the media and the way in which ghost stories are literally mediated. And the other is technology.
科克巷的故事。因为你的鬼故事书里反复出现了一些元素。其中之一是媒体，以及鬼故事是如何被字面意义上地“中介化”的。另一个是技术。
Because you talked about the new newspapers. Yeah. And you talk a lot in your book about... You talk about magic lanterns and about photography and x-rays and the cinema and so on, all in different ways kind of seen as ghostly and involving. And it's almost as though ghost stories, well, it's obviously ghost stories take on the elements of the society they are about. But there are particular things that come up again and again. So do you think almost that the cult of the ghost story, if you like, or the phenomenon of the ghost would be impossible without the kind of mass media and all that stuff?
因为你谈到了新报纸。是的。你在书里谈了很多关于……你谈到了魔术灯、摄影、X光和电影等等，所有这些在不同程度上都被视为鬼魅般的，并且涉及其中。几乎可以说，鬼故事，嗯，显然鬼故事吸收了它们所处社会的元素。但有些特定的东西反复出现。所以你是否认为，如果可以的话，鬼故事的崇拜，或者鬼魂现象，如果没有大众媒体和所有这些东西，是不可能存在的？
I see it all the time now because I spent 10 years as a film critic. And so I saw a lot of movies. And you see how a movie like The Exorcist will completely bring back the whole idea of possession which was virtually dead in America until that film came out and then the Amityville horror so-called Amityville Ghost which sort of created you know the Enfield Poltergeist and things like that. And it's just, as soon as, you know, the influence of the media and the film and everything is not to be underestimated. It's absolutely universal now.
我一直都能看到这种情况，因为我做了10年的电影评论员。所以我看了很多电影。你可以看到像《驱魔人》这样的电影是如何彻底带回了“附身”这个概念的，在电影上映之前，这个概念在美国几乎已经绝迹了，然后是阿米蒂维尔恐怖事件，所谓的阿米蒂维尔鬼魂，它创造了，你知道，恩菲尔德闹鬼事件之类的东西。一旦，你知道，媒体、电影和所有东西的影响是不容小觑的。现在这绝对是普遍现象。
It's quite extraordinary to follow. And then, so the ghosts that people are seeing or believe they're seeing are, they are reflections. They're almost always reflections of a wider cultural story. Is that fair? Yeah, and going back to technology, in the 1890s, you've got this extraordinary period in Regent Street where you could walk into a place and have an X-ray done,
追踪这些现象非常非凡。所以人们看到的或者相信他们看到的鬼魂，它们是反射。它们几乎总是更广泛文化故事的反射。这样说公平吗？是的，回到技术问题，在19世纪90年代，摄政街有一段非凡的时期，你可以走进一个地方，拍一张X光片，
and people would just, they blew their minds they could walk in front of a machine and see their bones moving, you know. And at the same time, it was more or less when the Lumiere, the first cinema was being made. And there's this like sort of six months where X-rays, who were not immediately used for medical reasons, but used for a while
人们简直惊呆了，他们可以走到机器前，看到自己的骨头在移动，你知道。与此同时，这差不多也是卢米埃尔兄弟制作第一部电影的时候。有那么大约六个月的时间，X光并不是立即用于医疗目的，而是有一段时间
very horrifically for uh entertainment purposes there was a sort of brief six months where cinema and x-rays were right rival forms of entertainment and you can see in sort of george mellier doing a sort of basically skeleton film as a result of the whole x-ray thing and uh it it said i put it in a footnote in in my book that apparently when they tested uh marie curie who by the way was an investigator a ghost investigator in her spare time um they found evidence that her cancer and so forth was caused by x-rays and not by what the radium and so forth she worked on so yes so that was how dangerous it was but of course also you get photographs don't you and so the appearance of ghosts on photographs yes is and it's again
非常可怕地用于娱乐目的，有那么短暂的六个月，电影和X光是相互竞争的娱乐形式，你可以看到乔治·梅里爱基本上因为X光热潮而制作了一部骨架电影，而且我在书的脚注里写道，显然当他们测试玛丽·居里时，顺便说一句，她业余时间是一位鬼魂调查员，嗯，他们发现证据表明她的癌症等等是由X光引起的，而不是由她研究的镭等等引起的，所以是的，这就是它有多危险，但当然你也会得到照片，对吧，所以鬼魂出现在照片上，是的，这又是一个
as a big cultural thing so quite early on photography was used as a way to debunk ghosts actually to do debunkers look how easy it is to fake photographs you know and so there's this famous photograph of York Minster, the facade of York Minster, people moving out, and they would be very ghostly. And indeed, again, when the first moving cinema was seen, it was considered to be, people remarked, there's a very famous review in Russia about how ghosts,
重大的文化事件，所以很早的时候，摄影就被用作一种揭穿鬼魂的方法，实际上揭穿者会说，看，伪造照片是多么容易，你知道，所以有一张著名的约克大教堂的照片，约克大教堂的正面，人们走出来，他们看起来非常像鬼。事实上，当第一部动态电影出现时，人们评论说，俄罗斯有一篇非常著名的评论，关于鬼魂，
all these people would be dead at one point, but yet they'd still be moving around. And the whole idea of radio was so fantastically spooky, these voices coming out of the ether. And the idea of mental radio as an adjunct was pretty quickly. And I think that lasted right up until the 60s, the idea of mental radio. So just to dip back into the 18th century again, before we come back to the third great story, I tell you one of the things that I found so surprising in your book was about Methodism, because I'd never put Methodism
这些人本应在某个时候死去，但他们却还在走动。而整个无线电的概念是如此奇妙地令人毛骨悚然，这些声音从以太中传出来。而作为辅助手段的“精神无线电”的概念也很快出现了。我认为这一直持续到60年代，关于精神无线电的概念。所以，在我们回到第三个伟大的故事之前，让我们再回到18世纪，我告诉你，我在你的书里发现的一件让我非常惊讶的事情是关于卫理公会，因为我从来没有把卫理公会
and ghosts together as sort of interlinked phenomena. But John Wesley, am I right, was a great believer in ghosts and belief in ghosts in the 18th century was a kind of a marker of being a methodist now that is that have i got that right yes uh i think boswell talking of dr johnson was in scotland and he mentioned about ghosts and and his his extremely aristocratic ghost said i I fancy you are a Methodist. So you were talking about the class distinctions of ghosts. Yes, yes. Even in the afterlife, the British class system.
和鬼魂联系在一起，认为它们是相互关联的现象。但是约翰·卫斯理，我没说错吧，是一个坚定的鬼魂信仰者，而在18世纪，相信鬼魂是成为卫理公会教徒的一种标志，现在是这样吗？我理解对了吗？是的，我想鲍斯威尔在谈到约翰逊博士时，他在苏格兰，他提到了鬼魂，而他那极其贵族的鬼魂说，我想你是个卫理公会教徒。所以你在谈论鬼魂的阶级差异。是的，是的。即使在来世，也有英国的阶级制度。
Of course, the Methodists, and there was a Methodist clergyman involved with the Copley and Ghost, and he very much pushed it forward. And it's a sort of hangover of this sort of Joseph Glanville 1680s idea that even though ghosts were not God, they were part of a supernatural process which ended up in God. So it was like a very crude domestic example of supernatural power. And that was quite a powerful idea in the 1680s it sort of fell out of fashion and then the methodist almost revived it and they very very over the years they kind of very quietly dropped it and pretended it never happened but their founder uh who was of course involved in well he wasn't directly involved but his family was involved in a famous poltergeist case again
当然，卫理公会教徒，有一个卫理公会牧师参与了科普利鬼魂事件，他非常推动这件事。这有点像是约瑟夫·格兰维尔1680年代思想的残留，即尽管鬼魂不是上帝，但它们是超自然过程的一部分，最终指向上帝。所以这就像是一个非常粗糙的超自然力量的家庭例子。这在1680年代是一个非常有影响力的想法，后来它不再流行，然后卫理公会教徒几乎复兴了它，多年来他们非常非常安静地放弃了它，假装它从未发生过，但他们的创始人，当然参与了，嗯，他没有直接参与，但他的家人参与了一个著名的骚灵案件，
and he really really thought that ghosts existed and so I think the argument he used well madam you may not have seen a murder but they've still happened whether you've seen it or not
他真的真的认为鬼魂存在，所以我认为他使用的论点是，嗯，夫人，你可能没有见过谋杀案，但无论你是否见过，它们确实发生过。
and that was weirdly his equivalence about murder not have seen a murder, but they've still happened whether you've seen it or not. And that was weirdly his equivalence about murder. But after the death of the Wesleys, it was quietly dropped. But there was a very active belief that because of the Witch of Endor and things like that, that supernatural things were part of a divine panoply and showed that there was much more going on than the basic everyday life worries, you know. Well, Roger, obviously we're recording this in the dead of night, but I sense that dawn is approaching and that cocks may soon be crowing
这奇怪地成了他关于谋杀的等价物。但卫斯理去世后，它被悄悄放弃了。但当时有一种非常活跃的信念，因为恩多尔的女巫之类的事情，超自然事物是神圣全景的一部分，并表明除了基本的日常生活烦恼之外，还有更多的事情在发生，你知道。嗯，罗杰，显然我们是在深夜录制这个节目，但我感觉到黎明即将来临，公鸡可能很快就会打鸣，
and we will have to melt upon the coming of the sun. But before that happens, and on the subject of clergymen, can we just talk about perhaps the most famous ghost story in England that involves a clergyman, which is the haunting of Borley Rectory, which in the children's book that I mentioned right at the beginning, which had the picture of Athenodorus and the ghost in Athens, had a whole chapter on Boreley Rectory with ghostly writing on the walls and white ladies and the rectory going up in flames. And I thought then that it was an incredibly odd story, but that was before I read your book. And I realized it was odd to the power of 20. Yes. I mean, it's a spectacularly odd story.
我们必须在太阳升起时融化。但在那之前，关于牧师的话题，我们能谈谈英国也许最著名的涉及牧师的鬼故事吗，那就是博利教区牧师住宅的闹鬼事件，我在开头提到的那本儿童读物里，里面有雅典诺多鲁斯和雅典鬼魂的图片，整整一章都在讲博利教区牧师住宅，墙上有鬼写的字，有白衣女子，还有教区住宅着火。我当时觉得那是一个非常奇怪的故事，但那是在我读你的书之前。我意识到它的奇怪程度是原来的20倍。是的。我的意思是，这是一个极其奇怪的故事。
So if you just sketch out what was going on in Borley Rectory, the most haunted house in Britain. It was, so it's this house in North Essex, which was a rectory, and it was built. It's early 20th century. Early 20th century, yes. So in sort of late Victorian times, Reverend Bull went there
所以如果你能简要描述一下博利教区牧师住宅发生了什么，那是英国闹鬼最凶的房子。它是，所以这是北埃塞克斯的一所房子，它是一个教区牧师住宅，它是建成的。它是20世纪初的。20世纪初，是的。所以在大约维多利亚时代晚期，布尔牧师去了那里，
and he had a big family and his son took over the living. And what was originally a rather nice house became slowly and slowly more decrepit. But by the sort of 1920s, they couldn't basically get anyone to live there. So you had to be a pretty low-rent clergyman to get the living there. And people went there. And the people who went there, and it already had been established there was a nun
他有一个大家庭，他的儿子接管了这份工作。原本相当不错的房子变得越来越破旧。但到了1920年代左右，他们基本上找不到人住在那儿。所以你必须是一个相当低端的牧师才能得到那里的职位。人们去了那里。去那里的人，而且已经确定那里有一个修女，
that walked through the garden and the Bull sisters, so there were sort of quite a few unmarried sisters who basically felt that the place was very haunted, and then it passed on, the living passed on to another man called lionel foster and he he had this sort of there's no other way of saying it kind of crazy wife and who was and there was possibly bigamy going on and she adopted sons and then children then abandoned them and then fled and uh and it was it's absolute psychodrama and harry price the famous investigator went basically hard it was six months i did almost like a closed uh a very famous
她在花园里走动，布尔姐妹，所以有相当多的未婚姐妹基本上觉得那个地方闹鬼很凶，然后它传下去了，这份工作传给了另一个叫莱昂内尔·福斯特的人，他有这种，没有别的说法，有点疯狂的妻子，而且可能存在重婚行为，她收养了儿子，然后是孩子，然后抛弃了他们，然后逃跑了，嗯，这绝对是心理剧，著名的调查员哈里·普莱斯基本上去了，那是六个月，我做了几乎像是一个封闭的，一个非常著名的
investigation using all you know absolute tip-top technology of the time uh and he was this famous ghost hunter who was a sort of very interesting character who was basically a paper bag salesman who wanted to be accepted by all the knobs at the SPR. And they all looked down on him. And so he went from being a sort of professional skeptic to a professional believer because he realized that he could do better. He was just going to make money. There's more money in the belief, isn't there, than the skepticism? Yeah, so he famously said people prefer the bunk to the debunk. Wow. And so, yeah, and so he investigated it for a while,
调查，使用了所有你知道的当时最顶尖的技术，嗯，他是这个著名的捉鬼敢死队成员，是一个非常有趣的人物，基本上是一个纸袋推销员，想被SPR（心灵研究协会）的所有大人物所接受。他们都看不起他。所以他从一个专业的怀疑论者变成了一个专业的信仰者，因为他意识到他可以做得更好。他只是想赚钱。信仰比怀疑更有利可图，不是吗？是的，所以他有一句名言：人们更喜欢谎言而不是揭穿谎言。哇。所以，是的，他调查了一段时间，
and there's a huge amount of interesting stuff. Again, very controversial. He appeared to study, he appeared to find all sorts of inexplicable events happening sort of spontaneous fires and things like that and then eventually sort of come the end of the 30s uh the church of england sort of sold it off really and it was um it was bought by a black shirt and because um who did you see that's the bit i didn't get in my children's he used to do uh black shirt village fates in the garden and then it sort of caught fire and there's a wonderful uh wood print of it in again one of my children books of the rectum fire and you can see all the
有很多有趣的东西。同样，非常有争议。他似乎研究了，他似乎发现了各种各样的无法解释的事件，比如自发火灾之类的东西，然后最终在30年代末，英国国教把它卖掉了，它被一个黑衫党人买了，因为，嗯，你看到了吗，那是我在儿童读物里没看懂的部分，他过去常在花园里举办黑衫党村庄集市，然后它着火了，在我的儿童读物里有一张很棒的关于教区住宅火灾的木版画，你可以看到所有
the ghostly figures in the flames it's almost certain that he set it on fire as a kind of insurance thing but um and then the ruins were haunted too and there was a famous photograph of a floating brick and i love that that the original photograph shows a floating brick but that was actually just a cropped version of another photograph in which you can see a builder throwing bricks in the corner. Dominic, you and your relentless scepticism. Yes, yes. It cost a lot of money to reproduce that picture, yes,
火焰中的鬼影，几乎可以肯定是他为了某种保险目的放火烧了它，但嗯，然后废墟也闹鬼，有一张著名的漂浮砖块的照片，我喜欢那个，原始照片显示一块漂浮的砖块，但那实际上只是另一张照片的裁剪版本，在原图中你可以看到一个建筑工人在角落里扔砖块。多米尼克，你那无情的怀疑论。是的，是的。复制那张照片花了很多钱，是的，
from the Underwood Estate. So, yes, but again, it's sort of one of these sort of – and to this day, you just get dozens of paranormal tourists just going there, camping out, sort of to the great bother often of the locals who don't really necessarily like it. And there was a dramatisation on TV about it. So it's sort of of sometimes in ghost stories, the people are much more interesting than the ghosts.
来自安德伍德庄园。所以，是的，但同样，它是那种——直到今天，你仍然会看到几十个超自然游客去那里，露营，这往往给当地人带来很大的困扰，他们并不一定喜欢这样。电视上还对此进行了戏剧化改编。所以，有时在鬼故事中，人比鬼更有趣。
And this is one of those occasions. And Roger, I know in your book and in other interviews, you've sort of said you don't really like the, you don't find it interesting, the conversation about, you know, are ghosts real? Do you believe in ghosts and stuff? But are there particular stories in the sort of english ghost tradition that you are drawn back to and you think there's really something very spooky yeah they're for me the hinton one
这就是其中之一。罗杰，我知道在你的书和其他采访中，你曾说你不太喜欢，你觉得关于“鬼魂是真的吗？你相信鬼魂吗？”之类的对话没什么意思。但在英国鬼故事传统中，有没有什么特定的故事让你回味无穷，并且你认为真的有什么非常诡异的东西？是的，对我来说是欣顿那个，
because that is just so relentless and over such a long time and such good quality witnesses and there's always been a problem with witnesses, also a class issue with witnesses. So until really the 1920s, the Society for Cycle Research wouldn't take reports from servants. They just would not run them, you know, because they thought they were probably up to no good anyway. So there's this huge issue.
因为那太无情了，持续了很长时间，而且证人素质很高，证人一直是个问题，也是一个阶级问题。所以直到1920年代，心灵研究协会才接受仆人的报告。他们就是不接受，你知道，因为他们认为他们无论如何可能没干好事。所以这是一个巨大的问题。
And there are quite a lot of instances where a lot of hauntings were actually problematic. Servants either getting in boyfriends and girlfriends or, you know, or stealing or, you know, or just taking out resentments on their mistress and master. But yeah, for me, the Hinton one still, it does give me the chills, definitely. But I think a lot of the best ghost things are probably not stories.
而且有很多例子表明，许多闹鬼事件实际上是有问题的。仆人要么带男朋友和女朋友进来，要么，你知道，偷窃，或者，你知道，只是对他们的女主人和男主人发泄怨恨。但是的，对我来说，欣顿那个故事仍然让我不寒而栗，绝对是。但我认为很多最好的鬼故事可能根本不是故事。
They're just little incidents. And of course, we're in a culture that likes a beginning, middle and an end. But actually, most ghost accounts you read are not a story and they never find out who the ghost is or anything like that. Do you think there's anything of 21st century ghosts emerging? And if so, is there anything distinctive about them, do you think? Yes, definitely. Well, you're now getting ghost stories about Zoom calls.
它们只是小插曲。当然，我们处于一个喜欢有开头、中间和结尾的文化中。但实际上，你读到的大多数鬼魂记录都不是一个故事，他们永远不会发现鬼魂是谁之类的。你认为21世纪的鬼魂正在出现吗？如果是这样，你认为它们有什么独特之处吗？是的，绝对。嗯，你现在开始听到关于Zoom通话的鬼故事了。
Yeah. So ghost in the machine. Ghost in the machine. Yes, definitely. Well, you're now getting ghost stories about Zoom calls. Yeah. So – Yeah, ghost in the machine. Ghost in the machine. And people getting text messages from dead people, people being buried with their phones and carrying on sending text messages. Yeah, that's a good one. My favourite one is haunted autocorrect.
是的。所以机器里的鬼魂。机器里的鬼魂。是的，绝对。嗯，你现在开始听到关于Zoom通话的鬼故事了。是的。所以——是的，机器里的鬼魂。机器里的鬼魂。还有人们收到死人的短信，人们被埋葬时带着手机，并继续发送短信。是的，那是一个很好的例子。我最喜欢的是闹鬼的自动更正。
How does that work? Instead of doing the obvious word word it would say things like dead buried in cellar that sort of wow i found that quite disturbing as somebody works spends every day staring at word document well there's been a film recently too about and i think it's a lockdown ghost film and it's just about four people in a zoom call and it's a ghost story about what happens to those people on the zoom call and it's. I haven't seen it yet myself, but it's been very well received. And a lot of those Japanese horror, like Ring and everything like that, is all about surveillance cameras, that sort of thing. We've very much gone back to technology.
那是怎么运作的？它没有使用显而易见的词，而是会说像“死在地下室里”之类的话，哇，作为一个每天盯着Word文档工作的人，我发现这相当令人不安。嗯，最近也有一部电影，我想那是一部封锁期间的鬼片，它只是关于Zoom通话中的四个人，这是一个关于Zoom通话中那些人身上发生了什么的鬼故事，而且它。我自己还没看过，但反响很好。很多日本恐怖片，比如《午夜凶铃》之类的，都是关于监控摄像头之类的东西。我们确实又回到了技术上。
And one other question that occurs to me, you talk a lot in the book about national specificity. So there's a fantastic line you have, which I was dying to quote from the antiquarian Francis Grose, 18th century antiquarian. He says, dragging chains is not the fashion of English ghosts. Chains and black vestments being chiefly the accoutrements of foreign specters seen in arbitrary governments. Dead or alive, English spirits are free. Free, yes. I found that so cheering. And presumably post-Brexit,
还有一个问题出现在我脑海中，你在书里谈了很多关于民族特殊性的问题。所以你有一句精彩的话，我非常想引用古物研究者弗朗西斯·格罗斯的话，18世纪的古物研究者。他说，拖着锁链不是英国鬼魂的时尚。锁链和黑色法衣主要是外国幽灵的装备，出现在专制政府中。无论死活，英国的灵魂都是自由的。自由，是的。我发现这太令人振奋了。而且大概在脱欧之后，
do you think English spirits will acquire more sort of national specificity? Haven't they just dug up a Roman skeleton with manacles? Yeah, they did. Yes, in a ditch. And I saw that there was speculation from some archaeologists or historians that that may have been a way of staying them, keeping them dead. I think that's the most popular theory. Yeah.
你认为英国的灵魂会获得更多某种民族特殊性吗？他们不是刚挖出一具戴着手铐的罗马骨架吗？是的，他们挖出来了。是的，在沟里。我看到一些考古学家或历史学家推测，这可能是一种镇压他们、让他们保持死亡状态的方法。我认为这是最流行的理论。是的。
Because the theory was initially that it's a slave and it may well have been a slave. Yeah. The fact that he's been chucked with the manacles on, which are quite expensive, suggests that there is some attempt to stop him from roaming. Well, you sort of, you know, in Venice, and there's a famous burial line in Venice, which was partly excavated, and they would find people with stones in their mouths to stop them being vampires and weights being put on the dead. And it's literally putting physical impediments on the dead.
因为最初的理论是它是一个奴隶，而且很可能确实是一个奴隶。是的。他被戴着手铐扔掉的事实，手铐相当昂贵，这表明有人试图阻止他游荡。嗯，你有点，你知道，在威尼斯，有一个著名的威尼斯墓葬，它被部分挖掘出来，他们会发现人们嘴里塞着石头以阻止他们变成吸血鬼，并在死者身上放置重物。这实际上是在死者身上放置物理障碍。
But yes, I mean, of course, but Dickens, of course, used clanking chains for yeah uh for you know christmas carol and made it very good now producers just sent me a text message that says um european ghosts are covered in red tape not chains that tells you where our producer's coming from anyway um tom the coat the cock has crowed has? The cock has just crowed, I think. Did you just organise that on your computer as a sort of special sound effect? No, it's because, obviously, the cock outside
但是是的，我的意思是，当然，但狄更斯当然在《圣诞颂歌》中使用了叮当作响的锁链，而且效果非常好，现在制片人刚给我发了一条短信，说“欧洲的鬼魂身上缠满了红胶带，而不是锁链”，这告诉你我们的制片人是从哪里来的。总之，嗯，汤姆，公鸡已经打鸣了，是吗？公鸡刚刚打鸣了，我想。你是为了某种特殊的音效而在电脑上安排的吗？不，是因为，显然，外面的公鸡
has woken up. You've done it especially for Roger. He doesn't normally do this on the podcast. The sun is coming, and I think that we need to get away quickly before we melt and dissolve. Oh, there it is again. There you go. Eerie.
已经醒了。你是专门为罗杰做的。他平时在播客里不这样做。太阳要出来了，我想我们需要在融化和溶解之前赶紧离开。哦，它又响了。你看。诡异。
Go. You wouldn't believe he's a grown man. Roger. Thank you so much. That's been absolutely fantastic. And anyone who wants to know more, do check out his sensational book. I mean,
走吧。你不会相信他是个成年人。罗杰。非常感谢你。这真是太棒了。任何想了解更多信息的人，一定要看看他那本轰动一时的书。我的意思是，
I saved it up for Christmas, but I think even in the dead of June, it would, it would send a shiver down your spine. Yeah, I read it this weekend on a blazing sunny day. Were you frightened? I don't scare easily, Tom, but I was absolutely fascinated. I was really, I think it's such an interesting subject.
我把它留到圣诞节看，但我想即使在六月的死寂中，它也会让你脊背发凉。是的，我这个周末在一个阳光明媚的日子读了它。你害怕吗？汤姆，我不容易被吓到，但我绝对被迷住了。我真的，我认为这是一个非常有趣的主题。
And the weird thing is, whether you believe in ghosts or not, it's completely immaterial, isn't it? Because ghosts are such a great window. They're literally immaterial. Very good, good yeah i'm glad you spotted that and on that great window into the past and on that note thanks ever so much uh we will be back next week thank you to roger thank you to listening uh we will see you soon bye bye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
奇怪的是，无论你是否相信鬼魂，这完全无关紧要，不是吗？因为鬼魂是一个很好的窗口。它们确实是无形的。非常好，很好，是的，我很高兴你发现了这一点，带着那个通往过去的伟大窗口，顺便提一下，非常感谢，我们下周会回来，感谢罗杰，感谢收听，我们很快再见，再见，再见，感谢收听《历史的其余部分》，获取奖励剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听，本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。